[Music]
let's go to brad in cincinnati hey brad
what's going on man
hey doc i appreciate your time thanks
thanks brother thanks for calling what's
up
yes well sir i need your help
with uh being able to persuade my
daughter to agree to continue her
treatment for ocd
so that is my original clinical
diagnosis ocd
so yeah um
i have been on both sides of this what
um
she have behaviors she have uh thoughts
what what what's what's your struggle
it's most yeah mostly rumination okay
room nation not so much physical so
uh
my wife and i don't even i think don't
even have a full
understanding of of all the things she
deals with because i don't even i'm not
even sure she's led us all the way in
sure because she's got this as a secret
from everybody okay as well and so she's
been to some counselors i'm like you
know relatively short we've done
supplements
uh we've uh i've even
done neurofeedback for a while we've had
some some
you know some small
improvements but overall
her attitude is just i just want it
going on i shouldn't have to have
treatment you know this is not fair
i don't i don't want this i just want to
be gone i don't i don't want to say i
don't want to ever think that i had to
go get help you know i don't want to
have to go treatment on it the last
counselor was an ocd specialist who
recommended
she considered medications and uh
you know there have been a couple times
when she momentarily agreed to
to take that next step but but she won't
do it she won't do it how old is she
uh she's just 17 should be 18 real soon
okay
um
i'd love to talk to her if she ever
wants to call in if y'all want to call
in together i don't know if she would
ever do that but i'd love to talk to her
um
been there
um
so for those who don't like i know ocd
gets a
gets there's like it's in the movies and
it looks like just somebody's washing
their hands a lot like that
think of i consider ocd a part of the
anxiety
family and compulsive thoughts are
compulsive behaviors right whether it's
washing your hands or cleaning one of
mine is locking doors i just know i take
two laps around the house every night
every single night when i'm in a hotel i
take two laps around the hotel my family
knows it i know it i don't fight it i
laugh about it sometimes i'll just smile
about it but um accounting i get stuck
counting corners sometimes it's just a
thing right
i went to war over it for years
and part of me
being able to just have a great life was
making peace with it right and then some
of the ones that were a little more
challenging like the
catastrophizing thoughts i did work hard
on those and now i just don't have them
anymore or when they start to spin up
i've got a couple of things i can do
between them
for those who don't know
i can't describe the urge in a way that
makes
people who don't struggle with ocd
understand it
other than maybe don't eat for 24 hours
and then walk into a room and there's
that smell of pizza
and you have to grab a piece or you've
maybe you've run a couple of miles in
the heat and you have to have a drink of
water it's a it's it's an urge it's
bizarre it's so powerful right and
addiction struggle with it so when what
what thoughts are spinning in her head
is she suicidal is she having
catastrophizing thoughts are she scared
of the future what is she what's she
spinning around with
well it started out with catastrophe
and that kind of thing you know mom and
dad dying that kind of stuff but it's
kind of moved on to a lot of things i
mean she uh
she's even struggling with eating now
yeah she has a lot of thoughts of uh you
know items being morally dirty you know
if she had to talk about something that
she didn't particularly like and she was
near a piece of furniture well now that
piece of furniture is dirty or now that
room in the house is dirty right
so it's it's
you know she's it's bleeding into a lot
of different things you know the
relationships are being more difficult
especially with me and uh
she's got anger issues she's got a
win-lose mindset uh kind of thing you
know we try to give her good ideas to
try to help her and bless her and then
she will actually say well i can't do
that now because that's what you
recommended so i'm not going to do that
you know that kind of thing and
uh some of that some of that you know
is is she's 17
right right well i know i thought that
but i can't tell you know where that
line is right and uh so it makes it hard
and i'm so frustrated and and
heartbroken because i worry so much
about where this could lead
you know if
if she doesn't get um help and and so
you know as a dad i'm like oh honey
please you know let's let's talk about
this so i probably you know i'm kind of
trying to be upfront and in a
non-threatening way but say honey you
know just trying to point out things in
the logic and that just doesn't work
that's it there you go that's right
and you're right and so when that
doesn't work i'm like oh okay what do i
do you know how do i how do i talk you
know i mean we can't even really have a
calm
conversation like you and i are now you
know so
so it's extremely difficult um i'm gonna
ask you a question it's gonna sound like
i'm accusing you of something please
please don't hear that okay i'm just
trying to get one more piece of
information and then we can get we can
get on down the road okay
right
walk me through
her childhood
was there
where did this stuff emerge from was
there were was there chaos growing up
was her frustration was her anger did
she have trauma in her past
yeah well
great question and i anticipate that
question
um and uh i don't think so i think she
would tell you you know that she had a
pretty good childhood up until a point
uh when her older sister left for
college there you go that's when that's
when everything that's when she
pretty much identified her life as being
destroyed and over okay
and how long ago was that
that was five years ago okay
and since then it's just been spinning
and spinning and then all of a sudden
it's yeah yeah okay at first you know it
was just
you know putting two and two together in
her mind that just didn't make sense and
we spent hours talking i mean you know
it's not gonna be that bad it's gonna be
fine you know and it's just it never
you know it's just like bouncing off of
her you know and she's just never put it
together and then it's just kind of
grown and grown and and so as i see this
thing just building this impenetrable
defense to protect itself it just it
gets me more and more concerned
so here
a couple of things here okay
and i want you there's i'm gonna give
you a couple of things you can do
starting today
all right starting right when this thing
is over
um
she may say no she's a 17 year old
right i mean she's a 17 year old woman
she can say no
but she's also a 17 year old kid okay
um
and mom's got to be on board too all
right right whenever
somebody's struggling
with anxiety or more than that
somebody is
mourning a relationship that meant
everything that got plucked out of the
moon
or when a kid wants so badly to go to
chuck e cheese and all of a sudden chuck
e cheese is closed and they get a little
bit agitated and i turn around and as
dad and say
it's not that big a deal when you chill
out
what i've just done
is i've given them information that is
contrary to what their body is telling
them
and for a child it makes them feel
insane
so when a
i hit i spank if i spank my kid all
right let's say you spank your child and
you say that didn't hurt
their body says that hurts
and their heart says my dad hit me that
hurts and their mind says i'm
heartbroken
but also this guy who's smart is telling
me it doesn't hurt and then the
it just goes
the machine the their brain does right
so
go back five years ago
the one thing that mattered to your
daughter for
probably a thousand different reasons
was her older sister
a person who was safe for her
she could laugh with could be honest
with and whatever honest means for a 12
year old right
right and then all of a sudden that got
unplugged
and that wasn't a
cognitive issue that is not an
information issue that is the
fight or flight the hey your tribe just
left you part of her brain that sounded
every alarm she had
and then the folks who love her
man y'all came in to help and you
i mean like hey it's gonna you're gonna
be fine it's not even that big a deal
and her body is saying help and her head
saying i guess it's not that big a deal
and now you got a fracture does that
make sense you see where i'm going with
that
yeah i do i do and so what we've tried
to do over the last four or five years
is solve a connection issue with info
and now the the relationship itself has
become a
um
an anxious interaction right yes yes and
these four-hour
conversations that feel like you're
spinning in circles and then one night
you go to bed you're like i think i
finally got through i gave her the right
analogy or the right metaphor the right
whatever
and she lays down and her brain's off to
the races again because the thing it's
trying to solve for is safe relationship
not info
yeah that's right and we want to do that
no i know i know you do i know you do
listen
so how do we do that so brad can i tell
you this can i tell you
sure you're a great dad and you love
your daughter
okay
i do and and i don't want you to hang up
being like well crap i screwed this up
i'm not telling you that what i'm
telling you is
i think moving this way
going west taking a right
there are some things you can do
different so here's what we're going to
solve for
we're going to solve for a relationship
we're going to solve for safety
okay now
i if you've listened to this show i'm
not a throw medicine at something first
there is a moment when your anxiety
alarms
you've been in a hotel before that gets
the the fire alarm gets set off because
there's too much
you get hot water in there right and
it's steam set it off
that is that's an alarm that's busted
it's sensitive it's too sensitive needs
to be recalibrated
um
there is a season when
low-dose medication for this is good
because it turns the alarms off so that
you can finally start having these
conversations does that make sense
perfect sense um and so if your doctor
has said hey we're in year five
and these things aren't working and now
your daughter is telling you i can't
even go into the things that are going
to help me to have help because they are
setting the that tells me that you may
have again i'm not a medical doctor but
you may have an alarm system that's just
needs to be recalibrated and reset
okay
so i wouldn't say you're a failure i
wouldn't say anything's broken i'd say
that's a like just get in there and get
done with it okay
the second thing is
is
this is gonna sound so cheesy and so
lame so cheesy and so lame you're gonna
say dude we've spent thousands of
dollars and hours and hours
if she would commit to this
i would love for you and her
i would love for you to say hey you know
what for the last five years i've given
you a lot of information
and the one thing i don't do enough of
is just hug my baby girl
which would you
give me a 30 second hug in the morning a
30 second hug in the evening just every
day
and mom wants in on this too
and she'd roll her eyes and just say i
just want to go back to my baby girl and
i know we can't go back to be in middle
school but you're about to go to college
and in it can we just start hugging and
i'm going to commit
if you want some info from me you know
that i'm here for you and you know i'm
your dad i love talking
right but what i really want to start
doing is
um
i want my baby girl back
and i'm gonna i'm gonna quit lecturing
you i'm gonna quit i'm arguing with you
i'm gonna quit trying to give you
another article and another thing
i want a 30 second hug with you every
day
um in the morning and i want 30 second
hug she may say dad i can't do that and
if that's the case great say me and your
mom are going to do 30 second hugs every
day
and because here's what's happened this
has affected your marriage too i know it
has because you have an idea on how to
do it mom has an idea and it's causing
fractures all over the place and that
tension feeds this spinning
cycle right it just turns into a cyclone
and so
i want you and your you and your wife
to drop your shoulders and i want you
all to start hugging each other 30
seconds a day
if you're able to write your daughter a
just a quick note go to walgreens or go
wherever and buy a stack of cards and
just write her a note every morning that
just says
i'm the luckiest dad in the world that i
got picked to be your dad
love dad that's it
that's it i love you right and what
we're trying to do now over over the
next year is we're going to try to solve
for a relationship
hey we just go for all of us going to go
for a walk after dinner i promise we
won't talk about covid politics or ocd
we're just going to go for a walk in
fact you can wear your headphones if you
wear your headphones though you gotta
hold mom's hand that's the rule but
we're just gonna go
for a walk together and here's what
we're doing we're just
slowly teaching the amygdala that we're
okay we're safe
and that sounds so ridiculous and so
cheesy and so oh my gosh what are you
doing dude
is she still gonna need medicine
probably
at least for a season does she still
need to see a counselor yes no question
but
what she really needs is to solve for
safe
to solve a relationship
and that's gonna start with you sitting
down saying dude i've given you enough
information to last us a lifetime let's
i'm done with it okay if you need if you
want me to answer questions specific
brain chemistry come ask me you know i
love talking about that stuff and i
still want to talk about baseball games
with you whatever
i just want to be dad
and i love you and i hurt with you you
know that i know that
let's get back to this
and then if she'll include you in
concerts she'll include you or you can
include her in concerts or whatever
things y'all like to do baseball games
whatever
invite her to those things we're solving
for
relationship and
i'm about 99 sure that you and your wife
need to go see a marriage counselor too
brad
five years of dealing with this inside
your house is hard on any marriage at
all any marriage in the world and
that tension fuels the house and so you
guys go work on you make sure your
marriage is strong that you all are good
and give that your daughter something
firm and concrete to anchor into
you're a good dad man you are
you're a good dad
your daughter's struggling she needs
medical intervention she needs
relational intervention
and she just needs her old man to say i
love you come give me a hug
let's start with some skin on skin
contact let's start with some hugs let's
start with some walks let's start with
some conversations that have nothing to
do with these other things
let's start with some experiences
together
let's start with y'all play video games
i don't care whatever it is
and let's let the professionals do the
professional stuff
and let her get her dad back and my gut
tells me my gut tells me
that over the arc of several months over
the arc of a year those alarms will
slowly start turning down her brain will
start going we're safe
we're safe
you're a good man
but yes if if medication's on the table
i i think you may be there okay sit down
with your doctor and start from the
lowest dose and work up is always my
recommendation
um thank you so so so so much for that
call